den den verletzten polizisten geht es
wieder relativ gut er hat ja eine
verletzung an der hand also keine
kollektion gott sei dank auch kein bruch
oder etwas über die seelischen narben
und wunden ist das schon gesprochen
worden also physisch gesehen wird die
polizei bald wieder zu alter stärke
zurück halten können
noch unklar ist es wie es dem studenten
gilt wer sich ja diesem ob
entgegengestellt hat am schlossplatz und
dafür bitter bezahlen musste mit einem
tritt gegen den kopf
diesen täter einen 16-jährigen hat man
ja gottseidank erwischt er wird 70 oder
er wird auf jeden fall wegen verdacht
des versuchten totschlags in u haft
gehen daran ist gar kein zweifel die es
diesen studenten aktuell geht wissen wir
nicht wir hoffen auch dass wir im laufe
des tages näheres erfahren